the nevada ballet theater is celebrating
its 50th season with a one-night-only
gala performance this saturday at the
smith center here to tell us more is roy
kaiser the nevada ballet theaters
artistic director congratulations this
is a big one this weekend thank you
thank you it is it's um you know 50
years of anything is quite a celebration
but a ballet company in las vegas
it's you know who would have thought so
uh
we are so happy to be here we're you
know we'll be finishing up our 50th
anniversary season after the gala this
weekend
uh we will have
some of our students from the academy we
will have the professional company of
course this is we're talking about the
gala we're talking about the gallery and
and then we have some guests coming in
to help us celebrate as well so it
should be a good time all the way around
so that is this weekend and then the
following weekend is when you wrap up
the season what are you wrapping up with
we're wrapping it up with a program
that's featuring carmina burana i don't
know if you know this score it is just a
big big piece of music we have 76
singers in a chorus wow on the stage
three soloists uh musicians of the las
vegas philharmonic in the pit conducted
by donato cabrera and the wonderful nbt
dancers on stage okay pull the curtain
back first how do you organize something
like this 76 performers you have people
singing and dance the whole thing what
goes on behind the scenes
there's a lot behind the scenes and i'll
be honest with you i don't do most of it
somebody else does but it's a lot it's
an awful lot to coordinate there are a
lot of moving parts but it's such a
spectacular
uh end product that ballet itself is
just beautiful and we'll open that
program with a ballet called who cares
by george balanchine it's all gershwin
tunes so we have a nice mix
and the company's looking great and
smith center too by the way if people
watching right now have never been to
the smith center here's two great
opportunities to go this weekend next
weekend what is a night at the theater
like
oh you know the smith center i have to
say yeah i've been in this business my
whole adult life and the smith center is
by far
one of the top
few
venues in the world i mean it is just so
incredibly beautiful
it's comfortable to to view there's
plenty
happening in the lobby before the
performance it's just
it's it's a great great venue so people
watching right now they're going to go
this saturday what's the one thing they
should be looking for at the show the
way is there something i go and go to
the theater with my wife can be the
first time going there give me one
little nugget that i can drop on my
guests about the theater on saturday
night you know we're going to have um
guest artists two principal dancers from
san francisco ballet will be doing the
iconic potted or the white potato from
swan lake
the company itself will be featured in
now i'm losing a jungle
former artistic director james canfield
choreographed this ballet
many years ago and we're doing a big
excerpt from jungle as well 50 years is
just what an accomplishment you said for
any business organization can you give
us a tease is what's coming up next
season we're not thinking that far yet
oh we're thinking that's our head
come on give us a little luggage
a little taste of something i'll give
you a little taste of something
in october
uh there may be a ballet about like a
vampire
i like it roy thank you so much i
appreciate it always a pleasure having
you on the show the nevada ballet
theater is celebrating its 2021 2022
50th anniversary season that one night
only gallery performance is saturday may
14th at the smith center jillian
well